euh vous êtes probablement euh la
personnalité que nous auditionnons qui a
l'expérience la plus longue dans le
monde ferroviaire puisque vous y êtes
entré pour la première fois en 1989
comme directeur de cabinet de Jacques
Fournier et vous êtes ensuite revenu
dans le groupe public ferroviaire en
1993 euh jusqu'en 1995 puis ensuite vous
y êtes revenu en 1997 pour ne plus le
quitter jusqu'en
2019 ce qui fait donc une période de
près de 25 ans d'activité euh dans le
group public ferroviaire a des niveaux
de
responsabilité très différents mais
toujours très stratégiques qui fait que
vous êtes l'un de ceux qui ont y compris
comme directeur général délégué avec
sous l'autorité deoui galouis puis
d'anne-emarie hidrac dessiné le paysage
de la SNCF
d'aujourd'hui vous avez donc été aussi
en responsabilité à un moment où les
questionnements sur les équilibres
économiques de fret SNCF sur
l'attractivité globale du monde
ferroviaire par rapport à une
concurrence intermodale avec la route
était durement questionné et où parfois
certains acteurs pouvaient s'interroger
sur la pérenité hors quelques domaines
stratégiqu comme la chimie ou comme le
nucléaire sur la pérenité et l'intérêt
d'une activité frite en France je parle
d'un doute qu'aujourd'hui beaucoup de
ces acteurs économiques nonont plus
puisque le désir du train est prê
de nouveau dans l'économie peut-être
plus qu'il ne l'a été au cours des 20
dernières années mais c'est bien à la
fois sur cette crise durable du fret
ferroviaire comme secteur mais aussi de
frit SNCF comme entreprise publique que
cette commission d'enquête entend
revenir ainsi que sur la solution de
discontinuité qui a été retenue par le
gouvernement pour répondre à des
injonctions européennes face au soutien
public à l'opérateur Fret
SNCF qui viennent un soutien qui vient
de très loin et qui est y compris
couvert ce soutien a une a été débloqué
en partie à une époque où vous étiez en
responsabilité vous avez donc euh
puisqu'on le sait l'un et ça nous a été
répété cet après-midi l'une des l'un des
points compliqué pour Bruxelles
peut-être le point compliqué principal
c'est le caractère répétitif de cette
couverture
des déficits accumulés de frais TNCF par
le gros public ferroviaire l'entité de
tête pendant plus d'une dizaine d'années
qui donc l'assimile à un soutien public
durable dans un secteur économiquement
et structurellement déficitaire avec des
aides publiques qui ne s'adressaient
qu'àun opérateur sur un secteur
concurrentiel là où les autres ne
pouvaient pas y avoir recours je
reprécise donc ce
cadre parmi les questions qui se
poseront nécessairement ici et que vous
poserons nos collègues mais que nous
souhaitons entendre dans votre propos il
y a la question de de la place qui était
réservé à Fret SNCF et à l'activité fret
disons au sens large transport de
marchandis dans l'activité du Group
public ferroviaire euh là où on a
parfois entendu ici devant cette
commission d'enquête je le partage avec
vous monsieur le Président que d'un côté
on avait sur cette politique de
développement du frais de ferroviaire
euh
une forme une stratégie publique de
politique publique insuffisamment
dessinée mais aussi au sein de
l'entreprise publique une prise en
compte de cet enjeu sous l'angle
écologique qui n'était pas aussi forte
qu'elle est
aujourd'hui dans les questions que nous
nous poserons aussi celle de savoir si
déjà à l'époque où vous étiez en
responsabilité vous aviez eu à discuter
avec le gouvernement français sur cette
menace d'une enquête approfondie de la
Commission européenne menace qui a été
activée en le 18 janvier dernier mais je
rappelle que vous avez été président
pendant 3 années où des plaintes étaient
en cours euh d'opérateurs alternatifs à
Fret SNCF contre Fret SNCF euh au motif
que cette entreprise avait bénéficié d'A
publique indu dans un secteur
concurrentiel comment euh regardiez-vous
ce risque contentieux qui était avéré
déjà à cette époque même s n'était pas
exactement de même nature que cette ce
ce crantage très fort de la menace avec
l'enquête euh approfondi de la
Commission et puis peut-être et et c'est
la règle mais c'est plus cette fois-ci
au citoyens au citoyens qui a une
expérience ferroviaire très récente nous
solliciterons et certains collègues ne
manqueront pas de le faire votre regard
sur cette solution de discontinuité sur
la situation dans laquelle Fred SNCF se
trouve et se trouvera dans quelques
années je vous rappelle monsieur le
Président mais vous le savez car vous ça
n'est pas la première commission
d'enquête à laquelle vous répondez que
cet enregistrement est est publi qui
sera disponible à la demande d'ailleurs
pour ceux qui le souhaiteront et que en
raison et en vertu de l'article 6 de
l'ordonnance du 17 novembre 1958
relative au fonctionnement des
assemblées parlementaires les personnes
auditionnées par les commissions
d'enquête doivent prêter serement de
dire la vérité toute la vérité et rien
que la vérité je vais donc vous demander
monsieur le Président de bien vouloir
lever la main droite et de dire je le
jure je jure je vous en remercie et nous
vous donnons donc la parole pour une
grosse dizaine de minutes à la suite de
quoi le dialogue s'ouvrira d'abord avec
les questions que je pourrais vous poser
celle de Monsieur le rapporteur et celle
des collègues députés présents monsieur
le Président vous avez la parole merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président Monsieur
le rapporteur je salue les
parlementaires présents et les
personnalités présentes je vous remercie
de m'uditionner parce que c'est une
question le Fred ferroviaire qui est
absolument essentielle pour la SNCF
depuis toujours la SNCF est née
quasiment comme une entreprise de fret
et d'autre part c'est une question vous
l'avez dit président qui est absolument
vitale pour la transition écologique
juste une précision moi j'ai été
Président j'ai regardé de mars 2008 à
octobre
2019 avant j'étais directeur général
exécutif avec anne-marieidrac et avec
Louis Galois que vous avez auditionné
mais il y avait une petite subtilité
c'est que le directeur du
fret était rattaché directement aux deux
présidents à Anne-Marie DRAC et à Louis
Gallois parce que la décision de l'Union
européenne de mars 2005 celle qui valide
le plan à 2 milliards qui est le premier
plan de sauvetage cette décision avait
confié au directeur du fret des pouvoirs
particuliers par exemple c'est lui qui
rapportter devant le conseil
d'administration de la SNCF directement
sans passer ni par Anne-Marie DRAC ni
par le Galois ni par
moi ayant dit ça je voulais juste à
titre préliminaire préciser que dans mon
propos j'essaie de distinguer pour la la
clarté des choses deux sujets il y a la
compétitivité du mode ferroviaire par
rapport à la route bon sujet sur lequel
il y a un affaiblissement dramatique et
une division par deux du frait
ferroviaire en France en une vingtaine
d'années puis à l'intérieur de ce sujet
il y a le sujet de la performance de
frit SNCF plongé dans la
concurrence en vertu de deux directives
de 2001 2002 qui s'appliqueent en fait à
partir de
2005 mais ces deux directives de
2001-22 prises par le gouvernement de
l'époque ne comportait aucun volet de
préparation ni de transition sur
l'arrivée de la concurrence en France et
j'y reviendrai c'est là à mon avis un
des un des échecs dramatiques de de
l'ouverture à la concurrence qui ne
comportait pas de cadre social harmonisé
pas de réforme structurell là où on dans
le domaine voyageur qu'on soit pour ou
qu'on soit contre l'ouverture à la
concurrence voyageur a comporté bah un
cadre social harmonisé et des éléments
de
réforme juste avant je voudrais parce
que vous m'y incitez dire un mot sur la
place de du FR ferroviaire SNCF dans
l'entreprise et là je vais tentant dire
nous parce que même si c'est passé pour
moi depuis plus de 4 ans j'essaie de me
remettre dans ce que c'était à
l'époque
bien sûr il y a toujours eu à la SNCF
depuis les années 80 une pression
extérieure très forte en faveur du
TGV sont les présidents de la République
qui annoncent la construction de ligne
TGV Nicolas Sarkozi en avait annoncé
trois le président de la République
actuelle après avoir levé le stylo en a
annoncé 5 en
2020 22 et donc on comprend que la
couverture du territoire en matière de
grande vitesse est un sujet qui a une
force politique peu commune mais à
l'intérieur de l'entreprise on le vit
pas comme ça
euh on le vit certes comme comme une
activité qui qui permet au train de
retrouver de la compétitivité mais dans
la culture et dans le je vais revenir
dans le service public on vit les trains
de la vie quotidienne et le transport
des marchandises comme des missions tout
aussi nobles que la grande vitesse
et je me rappelle et j'ai regardé avant
cette audition que dans la lettre de
mission que j'ai reçu du président de la
République en 2008 je me rappelle avoir
fait insérer une phrase je me souviens
moi-même l'avoir fait qui disait vous
devrait redonner au groupe SNCF une
place centrale dans le transport et la
logistique des marchandises en proposant
des solutions compétitives pour gérer
les chaînes
logistiques et la lettre enchaîne en
disant pérenité viabilité et croissance
du mode
ferroviaire dans le contexte nouveau de
la concurrence
intramodale et moi la première décision
que j'ai prise c'est de créer une
branche transport et logistique des
marchandises qui était la première
parote d'importance de la SNCF plus de
10 milliards et à l'intérieur de
laquelle il y avait toutes les activités
de frit ferroviaire donc le fret mais
aussi le transport combiné mais aussi
les autoroutes ferroviaires mais aussi
et cetera et cetera
ce que je veux ce dont je veux témoigner
devant la votre commission c'est que
euh collectivement dans l'entreprise on
s'est toujours battu pour le frais de
ferroviaire parce que profondément la
SNCF se sent
légitime légitime dans le fra de
ferroviaire c'est très compliqué le fra
ferroviaire vous l'avez touché
euh on a eu évidemment des conseils de
lâcher le wagon isolé on a tenu bon sur
le wagon isolé
on n jamais abandonné le vagon isolé de
la même façon il était devenu habituel
de se moquer pour pas être plus
méchant du Fret SNCF à très très haut
niveau jusqu'au sommet de l'État en
parlant de train frit perdus en
parlant du fait que les trains de fret
avancit moins vite que les
vélos sans parler de la perte à bissal
enfin cheminau du fret ont toujours été
sous un un monceau de critique et de
remarques assez
àerbe mais pour autant et je m'arrête là
il y avait une fierté de faire ce métier
parce que ce métier est à la fois vital
et ce métier est essentiel pour la
SNCF et je veux en profiter pour dire
que les cheminau du fret sont ceux qui
ont connu les réformes les plus
difficiles les plus lourd les plus
brusques peut-être et qu'ils ont tenu
bon avec leurs dirigeants locaux et avec
des gens comme comme Luc Nadal ou Sylvie
Charles après Francis roltangi Olivier
marambau moi c'est c'est une branche de
la SNCF à l'égard de laquelle j'ai
toujours eu le plus grand respect cont
tenu de de du contexte que je que je
vous dis
et et la mobilisation des
salariés la culture
le redressement de cette activité c'est
pas un 20 mots je donnerai trois
chiffres tout à l'heure alors maintenant
je reviens d'un mot sur la question du
mode ferroviaire j'abandonne la SNCF je
dis un mot sur le
mode pendant les années que j'ai connu
c'est-à-dire presque 12 années on n pas
cessé de plaider de plaider de plaider
pour on va dire des conditions de
concurrence qui soi
supportable
j'ai regardé d'ailleurs les les
auditions parlementaires auxquelles j'ai
eu le privilège de
participer rééquilibrage de la
concurrence RA route l'imitation
réglementaire du transport routier pour
le transit comme ça existe en Autriche
et en Suisse harmonisation des
conditions sociales entre le rail et la
route taxe carbone qui a été un vrai
coup de Massu sur la tête parce que voté
en
nous avons bâti toute notre stratégie
sur le fait qu'il y allait avoir les
cotaxes voté en 2009 et abandonné en
2013 et on a eu du mal à s'en remettre
parce que elle était un élément
essentiel pour rééquilibrer le rail et
la route et puis on s'est battu et je je
je l'ai dit en en audition parlementaire
on s'est battu pour que le vagon isolé
soit reconnu comme une activité
d'intérêt général et peut-être de
service public c'est-à-dire qu'elle soit
contractualisée et c'était d'autant
moins
fou que les trains de nuit ont été
reconnus comme une activité de service
public en
2009 par Thierry Mariani alors ministre
des
Transports et donc il nous paraissait
légitime que le vagon isolé puisse être
considéré comme une activité de service
public
contractualisée
voilà quelle est l'analyse qu'on fait de
ça bah on n' pas été bon on n pas
convaincu ça c'est clair on n' pas
réussi à convaincre et peut-être que la
sous-performance de fret SNCF pesait
dans le débat et qu'étant donné qu'on
avait une image contrastée peut-être que
les responsables politiques nétaient pas
très engagés à faire cette bascule et en
fait cette bascule n'est venue qu'avec
l'urgence écologique vous l'avez
vous-même rappeler en outre beaucoup de
ces sujets étaient traités au niveau
européen et alors au niveau européen
c'était la cata c'est-à-dire que
l'ambiance de l'époque n'a rien à voir
avec l'ambiance d'aujourd'hui c'était
une ambiance autour de la séparation de
l'infrastructure et du transporteur ce
qu'on appelle l'
buundling qui était prescrit par la
Commission européenne l'ambiance
c'était aussi une ambiance assez
hostile au groupes aux entreprises crise
publique historique et puis c'était une
ambiance dans lequelle la concurrence
intramodale devait avoir réponse à
tout et donc on n' pas réussi à
convaincre et et ce virage de la
politique des transports a été tardif
sans aucun
doute beaucoup de responsables
politiques qui
soit dans les gouvernements ou qui soit
au Parlement avait déjà une conscience
qu'il fallait que ça change et se
battait pour que ça change mais entre on
va dire l'intuition politique la
conviction politique et la réalité
concrète je pense qu'il y a eu un écart
considérable il y a eu des choses de
fait par exemple les péages ont été
réduit de moitié il y a eu un petit
contrat de service public pour
l'autoroute ferroviaire alpine il y a eu
des investissements pour moderniser
certains triages il y a eu
quelques itinéraires qui ont été
réservés au fret comme par exemple CERC
Gizor qui mène au port de la Normandie
ou la rive droite du Rhône mais à côté
de ça ce qu'on a appelé entre nous le
plan borlau de 2009 qui s'appelait
nouveau transport écologique des
marchandises ça veut dire que
l'intuition était là nouveau transport
écologique des marchandises mais ce plan
n'a pas pu être mis en œuvre et
l'illustration la plus éclatante c'est
le contournement ferroviaire de
l'agglomération lyonnaise
CFAL où passe environ presque 50 % du
frais ferroviaire français la décision
date de 2009 on est en
2023 et il y a aucune
perspective voilà donc voilà pour le
contexte dans lequel on a agi alors
maintenant pour terminer sur la
transformation de fret
SNCF moi ce dont je peux témoigner
devant la commission c'est évidemment au
début
euh on souffrait d'un nombre de
faiblesse considérable hein il vaut
mieux l'admettre tout de suite parmi ces
faiblesse j'ai essayé d'en lister euh
euh plusieurs
euh évidemment euh on avait des coups de
structure qui était sans rapport avec
nos concurrents on était déployé sur
ensemble du territoire avec toutes les
fonctions et cetera on navait pas au
tout début les moyens de production
étaient pas dédiés à l'activité frite
donc les conducteurs étaient partagés
euh je me suis permis de changer ça en
2009 en décidant la ce qui s'appelle
dans le jargon la dédication des
conducteurs du
fret on avait des relations clients qui
étaient pas bonnes et puis euh ce que
Louis Gallois appelait dans un mot
restit un peu célèbre dans l'entreprise
la grevie culture avait un impact som
toute limité sur les voyageurs parce
qu'une fois la greffe terminée les
voyageurs revenaient au train
mais les
chargeurs lorsque la grff se terminait
ils avaient souvent fait d'autres choix
pour des tas de raisons donc nous avions
nos propres turpitudes et la
transformation qu'on a faite pendant
cette douzaine d'années elle a été je le
reconnais devant la commission assez
brutale les chiffres c'est le seul
chiffre que je
donnerai on a baissé le nombre de
locomotive de 70
% mais on en a profité pour les changer
toutes donc on a acheté un parc neu le
parc de wagons de 75
% les effectifs de Chemino 50 % même
s'il y a eu aucun
licenciement et le chiffre d'affair a
baissé de 35
% et donc et je ne parle pas des
organisations du travail qui ont été
complètement remise à plat de la
polyvalence de la culture client donc on
a
euh on a assumé un choix de réforme qui
a été particulièrement difficile et
douloureux
euh malgré tout le le contexte est resté
quand même très
défavorable la
désindustrialisation qui était massive à
l'époque hein on est dans la décennie
2020 le retrait de l'écotaxe j'en ai
parlé l'absence de cadre social
harmonisé
le paiement par
frite de ce qu'on appelle dans notre
jargon le T2 c'està-dire la totalité des
charg de retraite afférente au régime
Chemino qui présenta 40 millions par an
pour frê SNCF et les concurrents
payaient zéro donc fret était pénalisé
fret et cheminau du fret avaient le
sentiment de faire la course avec des
pieds de plomb pendant cette
période malgré tout on s'est B d je je
je l'ai dit on a réussi me semble-t-il à
améliorer la performance de fret
euh je voudrais terminer euh en disant
une peu sorte de de de vision d'ensemble
euh oui monsieur le Président
euh nous avons assumé SNCF a assumé le
PDG que je l'étais nous avons assumé une
solidarité complète à l'égard de
l'activité du fret c'est-à-dire qu'on a
assumé les
pertes on a assumé la
dette qui était dans SNCF mobilité et on
a assumé la restructuration extrêmement
puissante et les reclassements qui qui
s'en sont suivis on a assumé le vagon
isolé dont beaucoup de personnes nous
disaient mais il suffirait que vous
lâchiez le vagon isolé pour que il
resterait uniquement les trains entiers
et ça redeviendrait à l'équilibre donc
oui sous ma présidence on a assumé cela
mais mais pour la raison que j'ai
indiqué en introduction c'est-à-dire ça
fait partie de la SNCF c'est une
activité d'intérêt général voire de
service public et ça fait partie des
missions dont la SNCF considère que ce
sont des missions dont elle elle peut
être fière j'ai débordé un petit
peu donc quelques questions merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président et aussi
de la la conviction qui se s'entendait
dans vos propos quelques quelques
questions pour pour commencer avant de
céder la parole à Monsieur le
Rapporteur tout à l'heure en en évoquant
les le soutien des politiques publiques
à cette activité de fredncf vous disiez
on a demandé on est allé on a essayé de
convaincre est-ce que vous
pourriez revenir un peu plus précisément
sur la nature des demandes qui étaient
alors les
vôtres en matière de politique public
qu'il aurait fallu faire et conduire
pour soutenir fritnf je le dis ici et et
puis pour soutenir surtout le secteur de
du mode de transport du FR de
ferroviaire parce que effectivement il y
a deux sujets que vous avez bien
distingué deuxème réaction et c'est une
question un peu plus précise vous avez
néanmoins en en disant que certaines
mesures avaient pu être prises avant la
stratégie nationale de développement du
frit ferroviaire de 2021 euh vous avez
évoqué euh la question des péages je
sais que c'est une question qui est
chère à de nos administrateurs et euh et
du soutien à ces péages vous avez
notamment évoqué la réduction de ces
péages pour le fret euh comparativement
euh à ce qui peut ce qui pouvait être
pratiqué auparavant bon c'est une
question autour de laquelle on tourne
souvent parce que euh il est parfois
évoquer que le niveau de cespage le
niveau faible de cespage est
désincitatifs au sein de la maison SNCF
pour pratiquer l'activité frite et en
même temps si on fait la comparaison
avec des pays voisins comme l'Allemagne
il reste plus élevé que ceux qui sont
pratiqués en Allemagne donc est-ce que
vous pourriez revenir sur cette mesure
de réduction des péages très
spécifiquement et sur la question de
centrale de savoir si cette réduction
elle a été supportée à 100 % par SNCF
réseau ou si elle a été compensé pour
parti ou totalement par l'État
euh question un peu un
peu provocquante et pas forcément
agréable vous évoquiez les mesures de
réorganisation de frit SNF que vous avez
dû prendre vous avez assumé comme euh
comme président du groupe public
ferroviaire est-ce que vous diriez que
cette gestion était pour partie une
gestion par les coûts euh d'abord
peut-être avant que soit menée une
stratégie de développement et et enfin
dernière question je disais que c'était
une question un peu désagréable hein je
dernière question
euh vous n'êtes pas revenu sur le sujet
de l'ouverture euh du contentieux avec
les plaintes déposées par les
concurrents de fret SNCF en 2016 et donc
pendant 3 ans un peu plus de 3 ans vous
avez été président avec cette alors je
veux bien croire que ce n'était pas une
épée de damoclesè c'était peut-être une
épée en bois ou quelque chose dont on
pouvait considérer un de vos successeurs
enfin votre successeur nous l'a dit
que c'était quelque chose qui était dans
le paysage mais qui a au moment de la
transformation en enquête approfondie
c'est a été quand même un choc comment
vous regardiez ce risque contentieux
est-ce que le gouvernement français
avait déjà des échanges avec la
Commission européenne à cette époque-
làà et quels échanges avec le
gouvernement français sur ce sujet
pouviez-vous avoir votre niveau en tant
que président du groupe public
ferroviaire merci beaucoup j'ai essayé
de de mobiliser tous mes souvenirs je
commence par la dernière
euh en fait cette question des plaintes
il y a une plainte de la
deutscheoban j'ai oublié mais 2016 puis
ensuite les trois plaintes
Eurotunnel le repreneur de bcargo et un
troisiè que j'ai
oublié tout ça euh c'était parce que
leur filiale en France n'avait pas les
résultats qu'il souhaitaient
et qu'il n'arrivait pas comme nous à
rééquilibrer la concurrence
raroot et alors à défaut de pouvoir
rééquilibrer la concurrence raayroout et
devant les déficits que leur filiale en
France pourtant légère sans chemineau et
cetera
généré ils ont avec leurs avocats pris
un billard à deux bandes en faisant
entre guillemets des recours sur les des
aides d'État à l'opérateur historique
mais quand moi je m'en suis expliqué
avec eux notamment avec le président de
la Deutch band avec lequel j'avais des
rapports quotidiens il m'a évidemment
dit c'est pas vous qu'on vise c'est la
politique des transports mais é que la
politique des transports européenne et
française bouge pas en faisant entre
guillemets éclater la petite
bombinette du net d'État en France on va
peut-être faire bouger les choses donc
voilà un élément de réponse et deuxième
élément de réponse c'est les aides
d'État étaient géré évidemment par d'une
part la PE et d'autre part la DGITM du
ministère des transport et l'entreprise
si vous me permettez l'expression voyait
un peu passer les trains c'est on nétait
pas du tout en première ligne ces
plaintes étaient dirigées contre l'État
français si je reviens sur
les sur la première question qui est la
question évidemment d'ampleur qui est
qu'est-ce que vous avez demandé c'est là
où
la la conseillère parlementaire de la
SNCF a fait un
travail pour exhumer mes propos et je
prends juste une audition de du 10
octobre 2011 donc je suis président
depuis 3 ans sur le fret nous prenons la
création d'une fiscalité écologique
susceptible de rétablir l'équité entre
le rail et la route un peu plus loin il
faut réserver des voies au fret un peu
plus loin nous devons mettre en place un
cadre social harmonisé en veillant à ne
pas dégrader les conditions de travail
euh 4e un peu plus loin la taxe poids
lourd en discussion depuis 10 ans sera
enfin effective en
2013 bon pas tout à fait ce qui s'est
produit et puis des propos comme ça qui
sont répété dans dans toutes les les
auditions en 2013 je je dis faute
d'avoir été correctement préparé la
concurrence intramodal ne s'exerce pas
dans des conditions
équitables donc je ne dis pas que nous
n'avons pas été écoutés mais le contexte
de l'époque c'est pas l'urgence
climatique d'aujourd'hui et je pense
qu'il y avait une forme de d'hésitation
d'autocensure voilà je je je pense que
c'était très difficile pour les
responsables politiques à
l'époque de prendre le contrepied en
disant nous allons de façon volontariste
rétablir la concurrence entre le rail et
la route à l'échelle européenne et nous
allons réformer la SNCF pour lui
permettre dans cette concurrence de
jouer son
rôle sur les péages alors c'est une
question là vous me permettrez d'essayer
d'être simple parce que c'est un un
sujet de
thèse de bien public et cetera je je ça
fait longtemps que j'ai renoncé à tout
comprendre mais ce qui s'est
produit c'est que dans pas mal d'autres
pays
il y avait des aides plus franches au
frait de ferroviaire par exemple aide
réglementaire dans des pays qui
interdisent le transit des poids lourds
Autriche Suisse il y avait dans d'autres
pays des aides clair au wagon isolé du
conventionnement du wagon isolé comme
par exemple en Suisse ces deux
hypothèses là en France ça ne faisait
pas partie du schéma mental et donc les
responsables administratif ont trouvé
une solution consistant à réduire les
phéages de 50 % là où ils sont je crois
à zéro en Allemagne où ils étaient à
zéro en Allemagne à l'époque donc faire
le
mi-chemin et alors là je pense qu'avec
mon collègue du réseau on a dû ne pas
très bien s'entendre parce que pour lui
ça représentait une perte
sèche dont je ne suis pas sûr que l'État
allit compenser à SNCF réseau là-dessus
je je ne sais plus donc ce débat n'était
pas facile alors on parlait pas de somme
énorme hein les péages fret à l'époque
ça devait être entre 20 et 30 millions
d'euros quelque chose comme ça mais
enfin 10 15 millions d'euros pour le le
fret SNCF c'est beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup d'argent et puis euh sur la
gestion par les coûts moi j'aurais adoré
faire la gestion par la
croissance mais comme on dit à manufance
si on perd sur chaque fusil plus on en
vend plus on perd et mon collègue et ami
Francis roltangi il a reçu comme mission
quand il a pris ses fonctions il avait
reçu comme mission de Louis Galois de
faire 50 milliards de TK en France 50
milliards de tonnes kilomè donc on a
adopté une stratégie de croissance des
trafics mais dès lors que les conditions
de compétitivité étaient pas
remplies l'augmentation du trafic qu'il
a réussi à faire qui s'est arrêté non
pas 50 mais de mémoire à 42 43 milliards
de TK c'est soldé par une perte
historique et je me souviens du chiffre
tellement ça avait été à l'époque un
choc de 455 millions d'euros
c'est-à-dire que le fret SNCF avait
perdu 1 demi milliard d'euros et donc
une stratégie de croissance des volumes
c'est
possible quand le mode ferroviaire est
compétitif ça c'est même comme ça qu'il
faut faire faut faut d'abord essayer de
faire plus de trafic mais quand le mode
ferroviaire n'est pas compétitif
malheureusement on est obligé d'essayer
de maintenir le maximum de trafic tout
en essayant de couper les
cûpts merci merci monsieur le Président
il je donne tout de suite la parole au
rapporteur mais il y a un point qui
était particulièrement intéressant dans
ce que vous disiez c'était euh ce ce
retour à l'origine des plaintes de 2016
c'est c'est-à-dire je pense que c'est
comme ça que les membres de la
commission d'enquête l'ont compris que
finalement dans le regard dans
l'initiative que les opérateurs
alternatifs avaient pris à l'égard de
Fred SNCF il y avait une façon de
réclamer une généralisation des aides
publiques à travers une politique de
soutien au secteur et non plus une
politique de soutien simplement à Fret
SNCF et que le biais qu'ils avaient
choisi de prendre c'était celui de
l'attaque contre l'entreprise publique
pour réclamer quelque chose qui qui
finalement ressemble à des aides
publicques qui maintenant existent mais
qui n'étai pas dans le paysage à cette
époque pour l'ensemble du secteur c'est
comme ça que j'interprète ce que vous
venez de dire et monsieur le
rapporteur merci monsieur le
Président
bien trois questions peut-être d'abord
une un
questionnement
d'éclaircissement si tenter qu'il puisse
être apporter vous arrivez à la
direction du groupe en 2008
et
2008 à ma connaissance
c'est la fin reconnue du plan de
restructuration conduit tout à la fois
bien sûr par les plans de l'entreprise
et validé par la commission européenne
en
2005 pour l'aide
d'État nous sommes en 2008 est-ce
que vous avez à partir du moment où vous
accédez aux
responsabilités
connaissance est-ce que vous avez
participation
à différents engagements prévus dans
l'accord entre la France et la
Commission européenne à savoir est-ce
que si vous avez connaissance ou
intéressement au rapport annuel qui
devait être fourni à la commission
permettant de contrôler le bon
déroulement du du plan des plans de
restructuration est-ce que vous avez
connaissance ou
intéressement des dispositions qui
permettaiit à la Commission
européenne de connaître durablement
euh les flux financiers y compris en
interne du groupe est-ce que vous avez
connaissance enfin à titre
d'exemple et bien d'un audit
indépendant
qui permettrait de clore qui devait
permettre de clore le plan de
restructuration à la date de 2008 euh
bref
est-ce que dans les éléments prévus à
l'accord France Commission
européenne vous avez à partir de 2008 un
intéressement qui non
seulement soit celui de la conclusion du
plan de restructuration mais qui soit
aussi dans le
temps
calendé y compris jusque à l'alerte de
la RAF par exemple en 2015 ça c'est ma
première
question deuxè question euh vous y avez
fait référence vous avez fait un un
travail de réorganisation interne de
l'entreprise et euh des modes métier y
compris
euh vous attachant euh notamment
euh à la spécialisation des moyens
industriels et humains par activité et à
la création de filiale euh tout cela euh
pour euh euh semble-t-il suivre la
logique d'une adaptation au segment de
marché
euh quel regard euh portez-vous euh
désormais euh vis-à-vis de cette logique
euh que vous avez suivi euh pour
développer le frit ferroviaire euh en la
circonstance enfin dernière question à
un moment clé
euh à savoir l'instruction et
l'adoption du nouveau pacte ferroviaire
et suivant
euh vous avez
été
interrogé y
compris au sein de l'entreprise
vis-à-vis de cette
transformation de l'épique en
sa es qu' moment ou à un autre euh vous
avez reçu ou disposé de l'assurance que
cette transformation de l'épique en
SA et bien
était était validé par la commission
européenne merci Monsieur excusez-moi
euh merci monsieur je vais répondre à la
troisème parce que ça c'est extrêmement
simple j'ai j'ai lu dans les journaux
j'ai j'ai entendu des des des choses sur
le
sujet la gestion de la Commission
européenne sur les plaintes et l'aide
d'État c'est vraiment une compétence de
l'État et l'État est pas d'une
transparence dingue quand il s'occupe
d'une affaire délicate qui est à la fois
technique juridique politique rapport de
force et
cetera donc je crois me souvenir mais
vraiment je crois me souvenir que le
ministère de l'époque était en contact
avec la Commission
européenne pour présenter à la
Commission
européenne le projet de loi qui allait
devenir la loi de juillet ou de juin
2018 portant réforme de la SNCF et je me
souviens avoir entendu le ministre ou
son entourage dire on a parlé avec la
commission on leur aura demandé leur
avis et cetera l'objectif étant de
prévenir pour pas avoir à guérir bon
mais je n'en sais pas plus sur les
discussions qui ont pu avoir lieu
euh sur le le plan de
2005 moi mon analyse est la
suivante on a fait du mieux qu'on a pu
pour le mettre en œuvre et on en a mis
en œuvre les Prin princi disposition ce
plan était quand même assez sévère
puisqueen échange du milliard et demi
qui était autorisé il fallait réduire
l'activité réduire le nombre de wagons
réduire le nombre de locomotiv rendre
des sillons il fallait s'appliquer un
taux d'intérêt qui était le taux
d'intérêt du marché il fallait faire des
rapports il fallait atteindre toute une
série de d'indicateurs qui avaient été
précisés mais la vérité c'est que ce
plan il s'est
fracassé sur l'arrivée de la concurrence
parce que la concurrence quand elle
arrive en 2005 et il me semble que c'est
je vais dire une bêtise forcément parce
que j'ai un tout petit peu pas la
mémoire mais j'aurais tendance à dire
mars 2005 concurrence
internationale frait ferroviaire et mars
2006 concurrence domestique donc en en
un an ou un an et demi la concurrence
des ferles il y a eu 19 opérateurs au
bout de quelques années
et c'est très simple les opérateurs il
venaient pas sur le wagon
isolé donc s'intéressait pas à
l'activité qui était structurellement
déficitaire il venait sur le train
entier il venit sur Arcelor il venait
sur nestley il venait sur Danon il
venait sur les grandes coopératives
agricoles qui faisaient des gros
transports donc il venait là où fr SNCF
arrivait à gagner de l'argent et donc en
en peu d'années Fred s'est trouvé dans
une
situation enfin de trafic en milliards
de tonnes kilomètres et une situation
économique extraordinairement détériorée
et je me souviens que sur les tableau de
bord on parit on perdait chaque mois un
point de part de marché deux points de
part de marché certains mois parce que
tout simplement nos concurrents n'avait
pas ni les charges de structure ni les
charges sociales ni les rigidités
propres à la SNCF ni ni ni ni ni on
avait l'habitude de dire dans
l'entreprise on arrive en France avec un
algecoo et deux téléphones
portables et on pouvait utiliser
évidemment des cheminau n'ayant pas le
statut on pouvait utiliser toute une
série de personnels au sol qui étaient
des personnels détachés on est avant la
réforme des personnels détachés à
l'échelle de l'Union européenne donc ça
a été une période extraordinairement
difficile on a fait tout ce qu'on a pu
pour maintenir les objectifs de ce plan
mais je crois qu'il s'est fracassé
là-dessus puis sur la troisème
question vous me dites est-ce qu'on
aurait pu gérer autrement je je vous le
redis monsieur rapporteur on aurait aimé
gérer par la croissance on a
essayé mais quand encore une fois
l'activité
structurellement déficitaire parce
qu'elle est pénalisé par des conditions
de
concurrence on ne peut pas sauf à ne pas
être un investisse avisé c'est la
première fois que je prononce le mot
mais on n'était pas tous les matins à se
poser la question hein je l'admets
volontiers on n'est pas des obsédés de
l'investisseur avisé et encore moins de
de ce qui se passe aujourd'hui dans dans
l'actualité de fret SNCF mais on avait
quand même en tête pardonnez-moi
l'expression qu'il fallait pas faire
n'importe
quoi je donne la parole à monsieur le
député Thomas porte député de Sandi
monsieur le député chers collègues vous
avez la
paroleur
président il faut que vous coupiez merci
monsieur le Président moi j'ai j'ai
quelques j'ai quelques questions d'abord
je suis assez mal à l'aise avec le le
mot de grvi culture et et encore une
fois on l'a entendu plusieurs fois dans
cette commission faire retomber sur les
Chemino une partie de la responsabilité
du fait que Fred SNCF n'ait pas été à la
hauteur et n'it pas pu être entreprise
publique qui qui qui se développe ça me
dérange assez donc je le rappelle mais
c'est une parenthèse moi j'ai deux
questions quand vous êtes arrivé à la
tête de la SNC vous avez fait une OPA
sur go10 pour l'inclure dans dans le
transport de marchandises et on s'est
aperçu qu'il y avait une concurrence
entre Fred SNCF et go1 derrière puisque
d'expérience et je parle là en tant que
que chmino puisque je je suis
aujourd'hui en détachement on a vu des
entreprises qui sollicitient du
transport de marchandis dis et la SNCF
répondait non c'est pas possible avec du
train mais on peut passer euh par du
camion euh donc c'était vraiment c'est
une concurrence déloyal donc il y a pas
aujourd'hui une problématique à avoir
dans un groupe comme la SNCF qui veut
relancer le frais de ferroviaire public
qui est un outil indispensable pour la
tration écologique qui est moins
accidentogène qui a des vertus sociales
écologiques y compris de de
réindustrialisation de bassin de vie
très important et de conserver euh une
filiale comme Go 10 qui fait du dumping
social qui utilise des travailleurs
détachés donc qui Infiné coule quelque
part l'activité de fret SNCF parce
qu'elle est des tarifs qui sont
absolument différents 2è question euh
vous avez pas répondu sur la procédure
de discontinuité moi j'aimerais avoir
votre avis aujourd'hui sur ce qu'a
proposé Clément bonne c'est-à-dire 10 %
euh d'emploi en moins euh une part du
chiffre d'affaires qui bascule la
session de 23 flux qui sont les
transports combinés qui sont les plus
rentables aujourd'hui ourdhi est-ce que
vous de votre regard vous jugez que
cette procédure de
discontinuité mis en place par Clément
bonne c'est la solution ou est-ce qu'on
aurait pu faire différemment on a
auditionné quelqu'un que vous avez
cettoyé l'ancien ministre des Transports
Jean-Baptiste Dbar qui lui a dit la
discontinuité n'est pas n'était pas
l'option prioritaire pour moi il fallait
aller peut-être au rapport de force pour
obtenir autre chose parce que derrière
cette procédure est-ce que vous avez pas
l'impression que finalement l'objectif
qui est de relancer le fret de
ferroviaire public et tout le monde le
partage cette décision elle ne va pas
affaiblir un opérateur et le mettre en
difficulté pour un certain nombre
d'années parce qu'on sait que la
nouvelle entité qui va être créée ne
pourra pas candidater pendant 10 ans sur
le transport combiné va avoir un manque
de conducteur enfin ça va être une
période très difficile c'est votre euh
Louis Gallois qui l'a dit il y a
quelques minutes ici en disant que il y
aurait des heures sombres pour faire
tcncf au lendemain cette procédure de
discontinuité donc moi j'aimerais avoir
votre regard sur ce qu'a proposé Clément
bonne à la Commission européenne encore
une fois sans aucune garantie parce
qu'aujourd'hui quand on a interrogé le
ministre des Transports quand on lui
demande est-ce queon est sûr qu'avec ce
scénario la Commission européenne va
s'arrêter et ne va pas réclamer euh les
enfin va arrêter la procédure de
paiement des 5 milliards aujourd'hui on
a pas de garantie donc quel est votre
regard sur cette
situation merci beaucoup euh pour ces
questions monsieur le député alors je
vais vous décevoir beaucoup sur la
seconde parce qu'en fait au moment où je
suis parti de la SNCF j'ai dit à tout le
monde que ça soit mes collègues euh les
personnels les organisations syndicales
les administrateurs que je ne suivrai
aucun des dossiers de la SNCF et que je
j'observerai une obligation de réserve
absolue elle est levée parce que c'est
une commission d'enquête parlementaire
mais en dehors de mon témoignage au
procès de brettinie et de cette
commission parlementaire vous ne trouvez
pas une personne à Paris qui a eu de ma
part trois mots sur laasncf sa vie son
œuvre donc je j'observe une obligation
de réserve et je ne suis pas du tout les
dossiers de la SNCF je ne dis pas les
articles je ne et ca je reviens en vche
sur sur sur G 10 je je partage une
partie de votre de votre question
c'est-à-dire que au moment où on fait
l'OPA sur
G nos collègues allemands ont dans
l'orbite de la Deutch ban ils ont le
grand logisticien qui s'appelle shenker
et ça s'appelle d'ailleurs dB shenker et
tout le monde pense que les synergies
entre les différents modes de transport
la complémentarité entre les modes de
transport c'est le choix gagnant et
qu'il faut faire ça parce que si vous
vendez de la logistique par exemple de
l'entreposage à un client vous allez
pouvoir lui vendre du transport combiné
puis peut-être un train entier puis
peut-être ceci puis peut-être cela et
que vous allez devenir finalement son
partenaire
logistique mais ça n'a pas marché comme
ça parce qu'en fait
si vous prenez arcelormital ou si vous
prenez
Danon les grands groupes ne veulent pas
avoir accès vraiment un seul partenaire
ils font on dit ri en français alors
Cherry picking en français ça voudrait
dire ils choisissent les SIS donc ils
séparent leurs achats pour éviter d'être
dans les mains d'un seul fournisseur
donc ils vont acheter à la SNCF du train
entier non pas forcément ils vont
acheter du wagon isolé parce que la SNCF
est la seule à faire du wagon isolé donc
je me souviens par exemple que on s'est
bagarré pour conserver le trafic
ferrovière de l'asserie saint-chell
d'Apcher bon qui coûtait évidemment les
yeux de la tête parce qu' allait à
saint-chili d'Apcher pour faire du wagon
isolé c'était complètement
économiquement déraisonnable mais on
voulait maintenir le wagon isolé on
voulait maintenir la ligne donc on l'a
fait mais évidemment aucun de nos
concurrents n'était candidats pour le
faire donc je crois que cette opération
avec G elle a donné certains résultats
par exemple autoroute ferroviaire
transport combiné tout ça on a on a
réussi à faire des choses mais le rêve
de la complémentarité des
modes il ne s'est pas réalisé alors
quand on a cherché à comprendre pourquoi
c'est aussi parce que à partir du moment
où il y a pas d'harmonisation des
conditions de concurrence entre les
modes
c'est un peu la loi de la
jungle il faut harmoniser les conditions
de la concurrence à ce momentl bon bah
c'est le service client qui fait la
différence c'est la fiabilité c'est la
ponctualité mais là on n pas réussi
faute d'harmonisation des conditions de
la concurrence à tiré vraiment partie de
de cette
opération peut-être une question avant
de donner la parole à Monsieur le
rapporteur dans les spécificités de
certains
opérateurs soit de de frais de
ferroviaire ou même de frais de fluvial
à
l'étranger dans leur rapport avec les
clients il y a ce fait que quand il y a
des perturbations qui pe être qui
peuvent être liés aux travaux qui
peuvent être liés si on est dans le
fluvial aux étiages qui peuvent être
liés effectivement à des mouvements
sociaux mais dans l'ensemble de de ces
perturbations
possibles et bien ces opérateurs
proposent une solution alternative en
cas de crise c'est-à-dire
que ils ne disent pas leur réponse si je
caricature he mais de des bécargotou de
transporteurs de grands transporteurs
fluviaux de renus et à l'étranger c'est
souvent si d'aventure il y a une
difficulté pour transporter vos
marchandises sur le mode par lequel elle
transit d'habitude on vous trouve la
solution pendant le temps pendant lequel
cette perturbation dure de sorte que
vous puissiez ensuite revenir sur le
mode de transport qui était qui est
celui que notre contrat prévoit et dans
ces contrats qui sont liés qui lient le
chargeur à l'opérateur ferroviaire au
fluvial il y a souvent ces clauses à
l'étranger est-ce que vous avez cherché
à impulser ce type de sécurisation par
le transport en mode alternatif pendant
des périodes courtes qui peut être qui
peuvent être lié je l'ai dit à des
causes variées dans les les politiques
que vous AZ impulsé à Fr
SNCF alors merci de cette cette question
et de cette idée en fait quand c'était
ponctuel on y arrivait et puis par
ailleurs en discutant avec les
organisations syndicales lorsqu'on était
sur un trafic vital par exemple un
produit qui allait être perdu si le
train n'était pas débloqué et de façon
nonofficielle on arrivait à trouver un
compromis disant voilà ce train là on va
arriver à le faire circuler
mais quand on était face à des
perturbations
longues comme par exemple un éboulement
de rocher euh j'ai vu ça dans le journal
récemment entre la France et l'Italie et
quand on voit les volumes que Fret SNCF
sort par exemple de de Evian ou de
Volvic quand on sort 5 6 7 trains
entiers par jour quand on sort des
trains de véhicule automobile de poissie
ou de ou de socho il faudrait 300
semi-remorque qui circulent 24h sur 24
pour avoir l'équivalent de de de ce
trafic ce qui est donc matériellement
complètement ingérable
malheureusement merci monsieur le
Président je va vous poser une
question mais peut-être mais je
vousvoyer dans la compréhension de vos
propos
euh vous avez
indiqué visiblement le en faisant une
pierre angulaire
de ce qui aurait pu être un redressement
de l'activité frê et FR SNCF en
particulier que le plan borlau en 2009
le plan
borlau de marchandise n'avait pas été
mis en
œuvre et en
contrepoint il me semble vous avoir
entendu porter une appréciation assez
sévère sur sur la rapidité des
changements misise en
œuvre
souscouvert me semble-t-il de la
stratégie nationale de développement du
frait de ferroviaire adopté en en 2020
ou à tout le moins que vous
jugeriez encore quelque peu dans les
limbes c'est vrai qu'on est en 2022
2023 est-ce est-ce que vous pourriez me
confirmer cette cette appréciation et
surtout au final me dire et j'insiste
peut-être auprès de vous me dire si les
conditions à la
fois de ce que sera demain la filière de
ce que sera
demain
l'amélioration à intensité X du réseau
que sera demain la réindustrialisation
sachant le temps qu' convient pour une
réindustrialisation avez-vous un avis
sur l'atteinte possible ou non en 2030
du doublement du fret ferroviaire dans
notre
pays merci beaucoup de de cette question
alors pardon j'ai dû être
particulièrement peu clair parce que ma
vie ferroviaire s'arrête le 30 octobre
2019 30 octobre 2019 je n'ai pas passé
le 1er
novembre et je j'ignore absolument tout
ce qui s'est produit depuis et pour des
raisons que je vous ai indiqué donc je
je ne connais pas cette stratégie non ce
que je dis c'est que ce que j'ai dit
c'est
que quand on se remet dans
l'époque ce qui est terrible et et je
vois que dans les témoignages que je
fais aux auditions au Sénat ou à
l'Assemblée nationale on revient
toujours
là-dessus c'est que
on n'a pas conscience de l'urgence
climatique ou rare ce sont ceux qui ont
conscience de l'urgence climatique et de
la violence du sujet on perçoit certains
d'entre eux je je vois des des députés
des sénateurs qui qui qui poussent
là-dessus mais globalement la conscience
n'est pas la même qu'aujourd'hui et on a
un climat dans l'Union européenne qui
est je l'ai dit qui a énormément pesé
contre les entreprises publiques
nationales qui qui sont vraiment des
trucs survivances du passé on a un
climat pour la séparation entre
l'infrastructure et l'opérateur une
séparation étanche qui a été moi
quasiment le principal sujet de mon
mandat au sens stratégique c'est
que j'ai contribué à ma toute petite
échelle à ce que finalement on réunisse
et à ce que l'Union européenne arrête de
bassiner tout monde avec la séparation
qui était la doxa
absolue à la fin des des années 2000 au
point que nous avons fait alliance avec
la deutcheoban en disant on peut pas
laisser l'Union européenne casser le
système mais il a fallu deux réformes
pour que une réforme en 2015 et une
réforme définitive en 2018 pour qu'on
réunifie et donc le climat était était
celui-là et si on ajoute le fait que à
chaque fois qu'on parlait de concurrence
raayroout tout le monde disait oui on
comprend mais qu'il se passait
rien seul la concurrence intramodale est
devenue réalité et je l'ai dit moi dans
toutes mes mes intervention devant la
représentation nationale au secours ne
refaites jamais ça puisque vous vous
vous introduisez une concurrence
intramodale sans qu'aucune précaution
aucune réforme d'accompagnement aucune
période de transition ne permettent à la
concurrence
intramodale on va dire de faire son
travail donc c'est vraiment un contexte
extraordinairement différent du contexte
d'aujourd'hui et moi je suis très
heureux que ce contexte d'hier soit
révolue
hein merci monsieur le Président est-ce
qu'il y a d'autres questions monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le député Thomas
porte et bien puisque nous avons nous en
avons fini merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président de ce
témoignage assez précis et et malgré
tout et malgré cette réserve à laquelle
vous astraigz engagé merci beaucoup